today the Matt Walsh show Med students
participate in a bizarre incantation
ritual where they pledged to reject the
gender binary and show respect for
primitive medical practices this is what
modern medicine has become speaking of
modern medicine Canada has expanded
their euthanasia laws so that now
physically healthy young people even
minors can be victims of doctor-assisted
suicide plus the unedited portions of
Kanye's interview with Tucker Carlson
are leaked online the left is calling it
a bombshell scoop we'll see if they're
overreacting again
they are of course and even msibc is now
admitting that John fetterman is
mentally incompetent but he's not
dropping out of the race of course all
of that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Court decision to overturn Roe is a huge
albeit long overdue step in the right
direction but there's still a long way
to go to rid our country of abortion
many companies are bowing to the welcome
mob by donating to pro-choice causes and
candidates or reimbursing their
employees travel expenses so that they
live and work in a pro-life State they
can travel to a pro-abortion state
getting abortion should be back at work
on Monday but what if I told you
that if you're currently on a phone plan
with one of the major carriers you might
be supporting these companies and their
pro-abortion agendas with your monthly
phone bill don't let abortionists use
your money to fund policies you don't
believe in switch to Charity mobile
instead Charity mobile is a pro-life Pro
family cell phone company that's that
sends five percent of your monthly plan
price to the pro-life charity of your
choice you don't have to compromise on
values or good phone service Charity
mobile offers the latest 5G phones no
device or service contracts great
Nationwide coverage and Live customer
service based right here in the USA the
fight for the right to life continues
and pro-life causes need all the support
you can get this fight is not over it
only continues and you can help by
switching your phone service to Charity
mobile today call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
walls to redeem a free cell phone offer
that's charitymobile.com and mention
code Walsh
the University of Minnesota medical
school is prestigious has a great
reputation each year is ranked among the
best medical schools in the entire
country a man named Dr Robert Englander
is the associate Dean for undergraduate
medical education at the school and he
is like the institution he serves highly
regarded highly respected his resume
includes Yale Medical School Johns
Hopkins Harvard Medical School a
residency at Children's National Medical
Center he's around the ivy league
medical school gamut
and there was a time when all of that
stuff might have meant that the
University of Minnesota medical school
and men like Dr Robert engliter can be
trusted
but those days are long gone here's the
report from the Tennessee star quote
University of Minnesota medical school
students took an oath to quote promote a
culture of anti-racism during an August
19th white code ceremony white coats the
students said
um are themselves a symbol of power
Prestige and dominance therefore
students will quote strive to reclaim
their identity as a symbol of
responsibility humility and loving
kindness quote we commit to uprooting
the Legacy and perpetuation of
structural violence deeply embedded
within the Healthcare System students
said according to a video of the
ceremony Dr Robert Englander associate
Dean for undergraduate medical education
LED students in reciting oath which he
described as beautiful he said the class
oath was written by the students in
consultation with their faculty advisors
now you can't fully appreciate this
until you've actually seen the video
which was posted to Twitter by Chris
rufo and let's go through it now here it
is
with gratitude we the students of the
University of Minnesota Twin Cities
Medical School class of 2026. stand here
today among our friends families peers
mentors and communities who have
supported us in reaching this milestone
our institution is located on Dakota
land today many indigenous people
throughout the state including Dakota
and Ojibwe called the Twin Cities home
we also recognize this acknowledgment is
not enough
we commit to uprooting the Legacy and
perpetuation of structural violence
deeply embedded within the Health Care
System we recognize inequities built by
past and present traumas rooted in white
supremacy colonialism the gender binary
ableism and all forms of Oppression
well you're right this acknowledgment is
not enough your apology is not complete
I will not believe that the repentance
is sincere until Dr Robert Englander
demonstrates it through self-immolation
I mean literal self-immolation like
setting himself on fire rather than
simply immolating his credibility as a
medical professional and his dignity as
a man I mean that much he has done but I
got to see I got to see the the full
thing you got to go all the way
so as we heard there it begins with the
classic land acknowledgment where
members of modern Western Civilization
apologize for being members of modern
Western Civilization granted all people
everywhere on Earth are living on land
that was once occupied and owned by
other people all inhabited regions of
the globe without exception have been
fought over and bled over and four
um no other culture though apologizes
for this fact just as Native Americans
never apologize for their own history of
conquest and bloodshed this is a
confrontation that they are never
required to have with their own past
only modern westerners are stupid enough
for this kind of thing well the greater
concern is that is that this doctor and
these medical students are in creepy
unison
declaring the gender binary oppressive
now it's theoretically possible that
somebody could be a competent Medical
Professional even while suffering from a
terminal case of performative white
guilt and that's all the land
acknowledgment stuff signifies
but it is impossible that somebody could
be a competent medical professional or
even a semi-competent one while
harboring the delusion that biology is
some sort of oppressive patriarchal
construct and conspiracy
all of their medical work must must
happen
within the context of biological
realities if they don't understand those
realities or have pledged to pretend
they don't understand them then they
can't be trusted I mean I wouldn't even
take Tylenol if these lunatics
recommended it
because they are fatally compromised
and we're not done yet let's continue
as we enter this profession with
opportunity for growth we commit to
promoting a culture of anti-racism
listening and amplifying voices for
positive change we pledge to honor all
indigenous ways of healing that have
been historically marginalized by
Western medicine
I'm sorry what honor all indigenous ways
of healing all of them all are you sure
all
I mean most indigenous ways of healing
are based in paganism and animism you
know the belief that all things
including rocks and rivers and plants
and all that have souls and are in a
sense Supernatural this is the belief
system that these ideas are rooted in
primitive people it may have had some
useful medical insights about plants and
medicinal plans and all that but they
were ignorance of most of the scientific
realities that make modern medicine
possible so when you say all
are we including for example the
Primitive practice of trepanation which
is boring holes in a person's skull to
treat spiritual or physical illnesses
that's something that indigenous people
in this part of the world did especially
in South America
um so are we honoring that what about
bloodletting or topical ointments made
out of animal droppings and dead lizards
what about ritualistic and medicinal
cannibalism
is Minnesota medical school going to
start teaching those strategies too
in indigenous cultures most medical
issues are treated by Shaman you know
witch doctors who would get high on
hallucinogens and then dance around
shaking a magical stick or whatever
is that the sort of treatment plan I can
now expect from doctors who earn degrees
from medical from Minnesota medical
school if I go to the doctor complaining
of a of a of a back ache is he going to
say okay hang on a second and like dose
himself with some LSD and start dancing
around the room
chanting
perhaps so
because we wouldn't want to marginalize
those medical practices
continuing on
knowing that health is intimately
connected to our environment we commit
to Healing our planet and communities
we vow to embrace our role as community
members and strive to embody cultural
humility
we promise to continue restoring trust
in the medical system and fulfilling our
responsibilities as Educators and
Advocates we commit to collaborating
with social political and additional
systems to Advance Health Equity
cultural humility he says you know the
other thing that's annoying about all
this is that is that as always like they
they never are consistent in the
principle
um so so cultural humility in and of
itself I would I would agree with so and
there's not a lot of cultural humility
these days
which is why we we spend so much time
um you know tearing down statues and
monuments and everything and talking
about the sins of our ancestors and our
forefathers
um elevating ourselves above them
you know engaging in this kind of
chronological snobbery as uh as I
believe C.S Lewis put it
so so we're doing that
it's like people like that were that
lived before us were a bunch of barbaric
scumbags simply because they lived
before so we're better because we live
now but then at the exact same time
we're also told that well we don't want
to marginalize indigenous healing
methods
so on one hand there is no cultural
humility and then on the other hand
there's also at the exact same time this
like degrading the basing of yourself
where you're elevating these primitive
Concepts above you but all this is
racially based of course that's that's
that's how we explain the the patterns
anyway
this is a relief because uh they they
did also say there in that last clip
that they're restoring trust in the
medical system they're restoring Trust
by making me think that I'm probably
better off simply dying of any serious
disease I contract rather than
Consulting with one of these lunatics
that's how they restore Trust
but as always you know though this
footage is deeply horrifying though it
may chill you to the Bone to see what
modern medicine has become it is good
that you see it I would rather that they
utter these incantations in full public
view on camera than do it in secret
it allows us to see where we stand and
also helps us to understand that we are
dealing not with an ideology or a
political system
this is not merely you know doctors who
are partisan or have political biases
those kinds of doctors have always
existed of course
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about a religion it is a
religion unlike any other in the history
of the world because this religion is
centered around the fundamental
rejection of Truth
many religions before this have been
untrue
many religions have had false ideas
about the world but even the false and
untrue ones have strived for truth they
claim to be true they saw themselves as
an access point for truth as maybe the
only access point for truth
but this modern Western liberal religion
simply rejects truth as a category
now this is not ignorance
indigenous cultures with their often
counterproductive medical practices were
ignorance
through no fault of their own
all ancient people were ignorant they
didn't know very much about how the
physical world functions or why these
things had not been explained to them
yet many cases had not been discovered
yet
but the religion of leftism stands in
the light of Truth it stands on the
shoulders of people who have revealed
many important truths to them
and then it chooses falsehood it chooses
ignorance
as an act of will it chooses untruth
there have been false religions
this on the other hand is falsehood as
religion
and these cultists these religious
Fanatics are in positions of power and
prestige in our culture they run our
schools and our government and now they
run the medical field
which is something to keep in mind the
next time you have to go to the doctor
at least
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
for those who've been following the
story Vanderbilt hospitals agreed to
pause all gender transition surgeries on
minors this is a big win a left-wing
institution caving to pressure from the
right deserves some recognition but the
fight is far from over there's still so
much we can do to protect our children
from this evil leftist indoctrination
and one thing you could do today is
write a will you know many new parents
don't realize how important it is to
have a will in place but the sad truth
is that if you were to die tomorrow
without a will the fate of your children
would be left up to the state I don't
know about you but I don't want the
state deciding anything for my family
luckily my partners over at Epic will
make early estate planning incredibly
easy and affordable they bundle your
last will living will Health Care power
attorney HIPAA release and durable
Financial power of attorney altogether
and you could save 10 percent the same
time when you use code Walsh it only
costs 119 for a single person to create
a will and when you when you use promo
code walls you'll save 10 as well so go
to epicworld.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 on Epic Will's complete will
package that's epic will com promo code
Welsh
okay we're going to start with something
uh gut wrenching and stomach churning
this is an article written by freelance
journalist Rupa
subramanya uh which I think I got that
right on her sub stack and it's uh it's
a it's a very important article by the
way that you should go look up and and
uh and well written uh and it's quite
relevant to the topic today as it
documents the medical industry's further
plunge into moral Madness and by
extension the Wes plunge into moral
Madness
so assisted suicide
is becoming increasingly popular in the
west especially in Canada
and starts in Canada and filters down
that land acknowledgment nonsense grew
uh became a prominent became popular in
Canada and is filtering down now uh in
into the United States same thing with
the expansion of assisted suicide so
popular OS especially in Canada
and in Canada the laws have been
repeatedly adjusted to make more people
eligible for this sort of
quote unquote treatment
and it's getting to getting to the point
where in some parts of Canada
assisted suicide euthanasia is one of
the leading causes of death so common it
is
as the author documents in this article
it's become an epidemic and now it's an
epidemic that includes very young people
even kids
so I'm going to read some of this now
on September 7th Margaret Marcilla
called Joshua Tepper the Doctor Who
planned to kill her son
Marcellus 46 she lives outside Toronto
with her husband and daughter a nursing
student
she had known that her 23 year old son
Keanu vafayan was depressed he was
diabetic and lost his vision in one eye
and he didn't have a job a girlfriend
how much of a future and Marcilla asked
her daughter to log on to keanu's
account Keanu had given his sister
access so she could help him with his
email he never shared anything with his
mother what he was thinking where he was
going and Marcilla was scared that was
what Marcilla learned that Keanu had
applied in the Late July had been
approved for medical assistance in dying
AKA made maid
AKA assisted suicide
his death was scheduled for September
22nd in a September 7th email from
Tepper the doctor to Keanu and Tecla
Hendrickson the executive director for
made house the Toronto facility where
keanu's death would take place Tepper
mapped out the schedule
here's the email
hi he emailed
I'm confirming the following time please
arrive at 8 30 a.m I will ask for the
nurse at 8 45 a.m and I will start the
procedure at around 9 A.M procedure will
be completed a few minutes after it
starts
okay
let's pause for a second here to take
note of one of the most Insidious
aspects of assisted suicide
notice the language that's being used
procedure treatment right you're going
to a facility there's uh there's
appointments someone's emailing you to
confirm the appointment working out
logistics it sounds like a communication
between uh you know that you would have
with a dentist or something an
orthodontist
and the effect is that we are sanitizing
suicide we are sanitizing death we're
making it seem like something other than
it is
and this doesn't just make suicidal
people feel better about their suicides
which would be bad enough
okay I don't see any difference between
this and you see a suicidal person who's
that who's standing at the at the at the
edge of a bridge and about to jump off
and rather than trying to convince him
to step back from the edge you just try
to make him feel better about what he's
going to do oh go ahead it'll be fine it
won't hurt that much
like if someone did that I mean if you
were to witness a scene like that
someone still she was not a person
standing at the edge of a bridge someone
else shouting to them to make them feel
better about it it'll be painless I
promise you would uh you would think
that person's a monster what kind of
person are you this person needs help
they're going to throw their life away
we don't want to see that happen
and yet this is exactly what's happening
in in the case of assisted suicide and
as I'm talking about this I'm
remembering that there have been
criminal cases that I forget the girl's
name but there was a famous criminal
case
in this country a few years ago of a of
a a girl
who encouraged her boyfriend to commit
suicide
and he was depressed and she encouraged
it and she kept telling him that it'll
be fine and he was even in his car about
to commit suicide and she was coaching
him through it and saying it'll be
painless it'll be fine you know this is
how you make your problems go away
and she was charged with crime for that
and for good reason
yet this is exactly what is happening
with assisted suicide and it's happening
in a medical context and because the
person has a white coat
and can call themselves a doctor
Suddenly It's it's okay
but it's it's it's even it's even worse
than it it's not just making suicidal
people feel better about their suicide
it's also
um it's also you know making it seem
appealing
to people who otherwise wouldn't be
suicidal it encourages suicide in other
words
quite intentionally of course
the other thing to keep in mind as we go
through this and and we'll get to this
article in a moment
but it's worth emphasizing that we are
way past the point of euthanasia for
elderly people who are terminally ill
and going to be dead next week anyway
and I think still when you hear about
euthanasia that's what comes to mind but
we are way past that we're talking about
putting down like dogs
physically healthy people young people
people who should have long lives in
front of them
we are much further down the slippery
slope it is a it's a slope that some of
us warned would happen if we legalized
euthanasia at all some of this have been
warning some of us have been warning
about this for years
we said if we get if doctors get into
the business of Doling out death
as a way to to get around a problem that
you're having or to deal with a problem
they're having if it's a very serious
problem a fatal problem like a terminal
illness once doctors get into the
business of that there is no end there's
no floor there's no basement
and we warned about that and we were
ignored
but here's the thing we are always right
when we warn about the slippery slope we
are always right always always
we have never been wrong
we've been right every single time
maybe at some point people start
listening to us
you still have these morons who treat
the slippery slope oh it's a fallacy
slippery slopes of oh it's a fallacy
it's just it's just that we're we're
right every single time
continuing along says the procedure
entailed administering Two drugs first a
coma inducing agent then a neuromuscular
blocker that would stop keanu's
breathing he'd be dead in five to ten
minutes apparently Kano wanted to bring
a dog with him and an email to him that
same day Hendrickson said dogs are
welcome in the space as long as there's
someone there who will be responsible
for them during the time it made house
or so it was terrified you tried to do
everything for her son but it had been
rough for him
and then it goes into what you know what
he'd gone through in his life he'd been
through a lot of very difficult things
uh he was unhappy
and that's when he decided to reach out
um about being killed
now the story doesn't really happen you
know does there's no ending really to
the story certainly not a happy one it
goes on to say that after the mother's
efforts to fight against this the
suicide appointment was was canceled but
her son is still in despair he hates his
mom now for trying to save him
um though he he does he does he doesn't
right now have an active appointment to
kill himself so that's the positive the
negative is that you know he's far from
out of the woods and same for her the
struggle goes on
and that's how it should be right
because we fight for life we don't give
up on it and when someone's going
through
a time like it's a very very dark time
and you try to help them it's very
likely that they're going to lash out at
you they're going to start blaming you I
mean you're trying to help them and save
them and they're going to take it out on
you that's what her this guy's mom is
dealing with
but you keep fighting for it because
life is worth fighting for if it's not
then what's the point of anything
what's the point about everyone's
worried about nuclear war we might as
well just incinerate ourselves with with
nukes on purpose and be done with it if
life is not worth fighting for and
saving
we can't get to the point where we say
well this person is depressed and uh
they'll always be like this is no point
in him living anymore let's put him down
like an old golden retriever and move on
now you keep fighting for life
uh and then the article goes on to talk
about the the numbers right now and how
in Canada especially they are rapidly
increasing you know year over year every
year more and more people uh falling
victim to euthanasia and the reason why
it's increasing is because well we live
in a culture of death that encourages
this kind of thing and encourages
Despair and also at the same time they
are relaxing and relaxing and amending
the laws to include more and more people
and now as we said they you know you
could get euthanasia even if you don't
have a terminal illness even if you're
young and now they're even talking about
amending the law again
so that
children
without parental consent so that
teenagers okay minors it's it's uh what
they're called a mature minor Doctrine
under the mature minor the so-called
mature minor Doctrine
um
miners
can get euthanasia without parental
consent
so they're going to start killing
teenagers without parental consent
full-on moral collapse I mean just
complete in the West
and this is also the continued we talk
about self-immolation it's the continued
self-immolation of Medicine of the
medical profession
as it continues to
profit
off of harm
many such cases
and it's really the affirm the so-called
affirmative care model brought to its
inevitable and violent uh and and quite
grotesque conclusion
we know about the affirmative care model
when it comes to gender and someone is
gender confused and in despair because
of their gender confusion uh they come
in and they have that confusion Affirmed
rather than having reality affirm they
have their confusion affirmed and then
they just fall deeper deeper into
Despair and now the same thing is
happening with depression
a depressed and suicidal person comes to
the doctor and they have their
depression and suicide confirmed and
Affirmed
rather than saying no you'll get through
this it's not going to be like this your
whole life your life is still worth
living
they're told yeah you know what if you
feel like this now you're never not
going to feel like this and so you might
as well kill yourself
but they're being told
it's just
so barbaric
especially for those of us who are a
little bit older and have lived a while
and
you know we know that you can go through
times and let you can go through periods
and you can go through very dark periods
in life I mean many people have you go
through very dark periods and they they
can be so dark that you don't see an end
to it you feel lost you don't see the
light at the end of the time you feel
like it's going to be like this forever
and um and then in in so many cases you
you come out of it
and maybe there'll be a time in your
life when you go back into it that
that's part of life it's life is hard
it's and there's suffering involved
but when you're in your lowest moment
and you're suffering your most it
doesn't mean it's going to be like that
forever
that should be the message that's a
message of Hope but
it's not what we're getting anymore
all right
Kanye West was trending again this time
uh because of this article from Vice
says Fox News recently aired a two-part
interview between Tucker Carlson and yay
the artist formerly known as Kanye West
motherboard has obtained portions of the
interview that were edited out of the
final broadcast
these include numerous anti-semitic
statements from yea a strange and
lengthy digression about fake children
he claimed were planted in his house to
manipulate his own children any
statement that he's vaccinated against
covet 19.
Carlson used the interview which was
presented as a piece of landmark
television to hit on a few of fox news's
favorite boogeyman with yay's
enthusiastic dissipation the clintons
former president Obama covered
restrictions and of course the
Kardashians
but what the Turk Carson team chose to
leave out is just as revealing in the
version of the interview that made it to
air yay described what he said where it
was pressure not to support Donald Trump
when the latter was a candidate called
the singer lizzo clinically unhealthy
for her weight which is true and uh
anyway talk about Oilers matters we know
about that yada yada
so they they um they have some of the
stuff that was edited out and it's
mostly you know it's mostly just Kanye
rambling and relatively incoherent ways
uh so here's one example of one of those
clips
I'll talk to him if I see him yep
but I guarantee he see me I have visions
that God gives me just over and over on
community building and how to build
these
free energy
kinetic fully kinetic energy
communities where we impress we we put
the least impression on the earth we're
not building the the new New York
skyline fight that
we are humble
in the way that we present ourselves
we've got to rethink who we are as a
species
okay so that's that's a scandalous stuff
there that was the episode first of all
the real story here is that someone on
the production team presumably someone
on the production team
um someone you know I guess it's we
can't know for sure but someone involved
someone had access to the raw footage
uh leaked that raw footage from the
Tucker Carlson interview to the
left-wing press
so to me that's the real story
um and and because that that doesn't
happen that's like when's the last time
you that you've heard of that happening
and it's the kind of thing you only have
to worry about if you're a conservative
because it never happens the other way
but if you're conservative you always
have to worry about some secret leftist
on your crew who will just absolutely
betray you because he has no ethical
standards
another of the the
if we call it advantages that people
have on the left is it's like no ethical
standards no moral standards at all just
do whatever you want uh I mean some
leftist rat leaked the scotus decision
so obviously there's nothing that they
won't do
and what is the bombshell here exactly
that Tucker Carlson Cuts stuff from the
interview because it was off topic or
unintelligible or just not relevant wow
amazing I I had no I didn't know they
did that with interviews I had no idea a
pre-recorded interview I didn't know
that they actually edited and took stuff
out and tried to get it down to a
reasonable length so that it would go
out so it would go out on air and yeah
if there's if there's a if there's a
digression into something that's not
relevant or interesting or doesn't make
sense that they cut that out I have no
idea this this is amazing
bombshell devastating there are people
passing this around yesterday of course
leftists devastating this is devastating
devastating for who
no one is surprised by this this is what
of course now if I'm doing the interview
with Kanye and he starts going on about
free energy communities or whatever
which by the way that's silly but that's
also what you hear on the left all the
time this is I mean there are actually
it's like that's in Saudi Arabia they're
they're talking about trying to do
something like that they're building a
big community in a giant wall that's
going to be whatever it's going to have
no impact on the environment allegedly
so but yeah all that I'd cut that out
too because it's just who cares that's
no one cares about that it's irrelevant
it's a tangent
um as for Kanye
himself it's it's not terribly
complicated okay really so that all the
Kanye discourse I have to confess
I find somewhat annoying
and I I find it somewhat annoying on all
sides and I'll tell you why because
Kanye West
is a he's a brilliant artist
um he's brilliant creatively he has no
doubt about that
but he's not a philosopher you know or
or some kind of great
um thinker when it comes to important
social issues I also don't think he's
crazy as people claim I was going
through a psychotic episode I don't I
don't see that I don't think that's true
either
I think it just kind of rambles and and
lots of people ramble but because he's a
rich and famous celebrity this is also
fed his ego and uh and that's also
that's been part of his brand and his
deal for as long as he's been on the
scene his hat is the the show this
immense sort of ego and
um
sometimes in music it could be kind of
funny and then other times it leads to
stuff like this but so he's got you know
like like many rich and famous people so
you got the ego and it's in and the ego
is fed and he believes that everything
he thinks and says is profound and
Brilliant and he's been encouraged in
that belief by the yes men around him to
think that about himself and so he just
keeps babbling about stuff and much of
it is silly and doesn't make a ton of
sense
sometimes it actually is profound and
he's spoken powerfully about the
pro-life issue
and when someone says something powerful
and true about pro-life issues nothing
wrong with the rest of us pointing it
out and saying well that's powerful and
true
um he had a line also in a Tucker
interview where he said something like
an artist doesn't explain himself but a
leader does so we've got a very simple
interesting line I think it's probably
true
um something to think about so Kanye
will have moments like that because he's
a smart guy from a creative perspective
but again he's not a philosopher
and that's fine because most of us
aren't
the problem is just when we pick through
every comment this guy makes even to the
point of going through sifting through
raw footage of an interview for stuff
that was taken out he's looking for
deeper significance and then elevating
him as either a hero or a villain
you know making him into like uh you
know a a philosopher king or Adolf
Hitler
is it possible he's just neither of
those things like he's a musical artist
who's made a lot of interesting music
and he's got a bunch of other opinions
about things and many of those some of
those opinions are
I agree with and are interesting and
some of those opinions are totally off
the wall
also by the way I could tell you this
he's definitely not the first musical
artist who falls into that category that
would be like all of them who've ever
lived
being kind of eccentric
is a is a common trait among artists
and having opinions and ideas that are
objectionable also common trade among
artists
the only difference is that now we live
in the social media era and 24 7 cable
news and the internet and so just like
we're surrounded if someone is famous
for one thing we have access to their
thoughts on everything else
and uh so that's part of what's
Happening
unintelligible here's msnbc's report
about John fetterman this is from MSNBC
so this is them telling us this which uh
is interesting let's watch
we had a monitor set up so that he could
read my questions because he still has
lingering auditory processing issues as
a result of the stroke which means he
has a hard time understanding what he's
hearing now once he reads the question
he's able to understand you'll hear he
also still has some uh problems some
challenges with speech and I'll say
Katie that just in some of the small
talk prior to uh the interview before
the closed captioning was up and running
it did seem that he had a hard time
understanding our our conversations
uh
so that again is from MSNBC that is what
they are admitting about John favor he
doesn't understand
he's a hard time tracking conversations
in order to understand anything he needs
uh he needs closed captioning he needs
to sit there with a with a computer
program just to understand
and he's not able to communicate
and in a under under most circumstances
someone who is suffering this way and
going through something like this it
would it would evoke nothing but
sympathy and pity
there's nothing there's nothing uh
you know people especially as they get
older they have strokes this kind of
thing happens terrible thing many of us
have seen this in our own families
it's just that it's just that the
problem is
that
he's running for political office and
has chosen to admit to keep running for
political office
and there's a very good chance
well we don't know what's going to
happen yet but there's a very good
chance that in Pennsylvania they will
actually choose to elect a senator with
brain damage
who who cannot understand
basic human conversation
and they're going to put them in
Congress
so when that happens then it becomes
then it's something that we we do have
to obviously be critical about and it's
also it makes a lot of the pity and the
sympathy evaporate too because although
John fetterman is uh having the trouble
communicating expressing himself
he's still we would assume like has a
grasp on reality and understand what's
going on around him so he is choosing to
remain in the race
despite knowing that he is not competent
for it
knowing what his he knows what his
limitations are he obviously knows them
and he chooses to stay in there because
he's hungry for power
and who's it remind you of it reminds
you of Joe Biden there's another example
in most cases someone who's going
through
senility someone who's you know uh
his dementia Alzheimer's
in most cases you have nothing but
sympathy for that person obviously
but here Joe Biden and he might be at a
point now where he really has no idea
what's even going on but at least
originally as he was losing his mental
faculties he was aware of that and yet
ran for president anyway
because he cares more about elevating
himself and his own power than about
the future of the country so he's
willing to harm the country it harms the
country to have someone who's lost their
mind in the presidency and he was
willing to do that for his own sake it
also harms the country to have someone
like John fetterman in the Senate
um and he's willing to do that
because of his own lust for power
all right
we gotta skip ahead to this
I haven't even read this but uh you know
it's it's BS here's the USA Today report
Chick-fil-A has the slowest
drive-through study says another chicken
chain comes in number one
that's the claim
uh it continues Chick-fil-A has the
slowest drive-throughs in the country a
new study that tracked the 10 major U.S
fast food chains revealed at Chick-fil-A
the dreaded drive-through wait time is
an average of 8 minutes and 29 seconds
which includes time spent waiting in
line and then getting your food
according to report by in touch insight
and it Customer Service Company
um KFC a Chick-fil-A competitor came in
the top spot with an average of five
minutes and two seconds KFC what I what
I ordered something from KFC
drive-through six years ago and I'm
still waiting for I still haven't gotten
it KFC has the worst customer service of
perhaps any company that has ever
existed on the planet KFC and Burger
King maybe are tied in that regard
like their employees openly despise you
for being there they will go slower on
purpose on the on the rare occasion if
you make the mistake of going in and no
one hardly ever does go to these places
but if you go into a Burger King or KFC
they will actually like when you're
walking in
you see the employees moving around and
they're not moving around very fast but
they're moving around faster than when
you go up and place the order now they
slow down on purpose
you order a bucket of chicken and you
sit in line for four and a half hours
and when you get to the window
the guy opens it up and he's stoned out
of his mind and he's out of uniform and
still somehow though he's still mad and
then he he spits in your face and hands
you like an old shoe with some ketchup
on it and if you say well that's not
exactly what I ordered he'll just roll
his eyes and there's nothing you could
do because he's also the store manager
somehow
that is literally the KFC experience
literally that that exact thing has
happened to me
so how can KFC have the fastest
drive-through times unless you mean
unless you mean it's faster because
there's never anyone in the
drive-through
because KFC sucks and everybody knows
I bet that is what they mean so let's
continue
uh it says but that doesn't mean the
chicken chain sandwich the chicken
sandwich chain which is closed on
Sundays is completely slow or bad at
business a caveat to the study is that
much of the wait time is based on
popularity right Chick-fil-A restaurants
average 4.74 cars in its drive-through
which is much higher than the average of
2.76 cars among the 10 chains if the
study we're considering quickest average
if we're considering quickest average
based on number of cars Chick-fil-A
would uniquely come in first with an
average of one minute and 47 seconds in
that box okay well there it is
so so the headline is completely bogus
I mean how can you make the headline
Chick-fil-A is the slowest and then when
you read the article you find out that
no actually it's the fastest on average
well you do that because you're the
corporate media and you lie about
everything this is how Petty these
bastards are they just lie about
everything
you had to lie about this even this you
had to lie about you couldn't just be
honest Chick-fil-A has the fastest time
on average that's the headline that's
that's all that matters
uh but in the courtroom they also see
everything as political so they have
they have to find some way to twist this
into anti-chick-fillet propaganda they
can't just report on the stupid
Chick-fil-A story they can't just do
that
they have to find some way to twist it
because they see Chick-fil-A as a
political enemy
and they still see Chick-fil-A's
political Enemy by the way even though
the Chick-fil-A CEO a couple years ago
uh I I believe I have this right wasn't
he the guy who got on his neat hands and
knees on stage and like washed the feet
of a of a black guy it's a xb8 his white
guilt I'm pretty sure that that happened
and that happens and yet they still hate
Chick-fil-A so that just shows you what
happens when you gravel to the left
this is actually pretty outrageous
the study finds the Chick-fil-A is the
fastest and the headline says it's the
slowest all right
uh but I I did I think I pledged that I
would stop defending Chick-fil-A ever
ever since that groveling display so I
guess we just have to move on uh here's
the
comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
says I love how Matt breaks every hope I
have left in humanity and then says now
let's get to our five headlines that is
generally the pattern I have to admit
Timothy says Matt makes much stronger
anti-pitful arguments than Knowles did
yesterday well I'm um you know I'm an
anti-pit bull guy from way back in the
day I've been in this movement for a
while so uh maybe that's maybe that's
part of the I don't know if maybe
Knowles is late to the uh
late to the the struggle here
big bad briff says I work with dogs and
I agree with Matt that they are a more
risky breed of dog I've met plenty of
great pities over the years and I love
those individual dogs I would hesitate
to own one because they have become so
overbred and so and so irresponsibly
bread
and that is more risky to own a pit bull
now that's because you can't know what
terrible traits have been introduced
into their bloodline unless you go to a
responsible breeder you can't guarantee
that the dog you're getting is of good
temperament it's a much different breed
than it was 50 years ago pities were not
bred to be aggressive to humans
originally it's sad because they could
be wonderful family dogs the breed has
in my opinion but irrevocably ruined
though
uh yeah it is unfortunate for the pit
bulls I I agree
uh if and I and I also don't profess to
know all of the ins and outs of the
history of pit bulls
um really I'm I'm as you know I'm uh I'm
basic Common Sense guy I'm a simple man
in a lot of ways and so I just look at I
look at the information that's around me
and I I draw conclusions that I think
are pretty common sense conclusions and
so when I look around and I see that you
know almost every single time someone is
mulled to death it's a pit bull uh and
then I look at the statistics it just it
tells me everything I need to know uh
and and I am and I'm also interpreting
this information in in the context of my
belief
that human beings of our in of of are of
infinite greater value
than dogs
um
and
since I believe that when I see that
there's one breed of dog that poses a
unique threat to humans it's easy for me
to say oh well we just shouldn't own
these dogs anymore and if anyone says
well what about the poor pitbulls like I
I don't care I mean I care more about
the people I that's it it you know
so if we if we say you can on pitbulls
anymore
um
this is this is one case where it
actually applies that uh and sometimes
this logic doesn't work but when it
comes to dogs and the threats that they
pose in this case I could say that if
saying you can't on pit bulls anymore
saves one more kid from getting mauled
to death then I think it was well worth
it
it's not even close to my mind
um
Brad Benfield says I love Matt but his
argument against pitbulls is completely
based on ignorance and fear the
irresponsible owners are the ones with
pit bulls that hurt others I have raised
pit bulls for many years and I've had
almost have had almost 100 pit bulls
100. all shapes colors and sizes and
none of my dogs ever bit anyone or any
other dog to the point of hurting them
permanently
well that's that was quite a qualifier
at the end to the none of them have ever
bit anyone to the point of hurting them
permanently
so you've got two qualifiers none of
them ever bit anyone to the point of
hurting them permanently
uh
how many of them have bit people though
is my question of the hundred that's
actually an interesting case study
so you are claiming that none of them
have ever permanently heard somebody how
many of them have hurt people though of
the 100 I I you know you tell me
um they are still strong and powerful
animals I'm like all animals they have
animalistic instincts when provoked
irresponsible owners are the only reason
Matt is so scared of pit bulls
um I well again my it's it's not the me
part I don't walk around in in Terror of
pit bulls now if I had a rabid pit bull
running at me I think I would be uh a
little bit disturbed by that but my fear
is mostly for kids that get mauled and
you know elderly people those are most
of the people that not not only but it's
mostly people who are especially
vulnerable who end up dying from these
attacks
so that's where my fear comes in
and you know I already addressed this uh
irresponsible owner thing
but just to reiterate
um
I I don't think it's true that all the
pit bull attacks can be explained by
quote bad owners
I think it's just something that is said
I don't know if there's a lot of
evidence for that
you'd also have to explain what you mean
by bad owner irresponsible but also even
if that is true that that doesn't change
anything as far as I'm concerned
because a lot of owners are going to be
irresponsible that's just the reality
it's like the analogy I gave yesterday
rather than you know rather than
comparing pit bulls to guns or inanimate
objects that that comparison doesn't
work I think if you want to make
analogies the analogy would be with
other kinds of animals and so there are
many other kinds of animals that you're
not allowed to own you're especially not
allowed to own in communities uh in
neighborhoods
because of the danger that they pose
even though with many of those other
sorts of animals if you're a very good
and responsible owner you can probably
make those animals a lot less dangerous
but the point is I don't want to have to
trust that you are one of those expert
owners I shouldn't have to trust that
if you're telling me you have to be an
expert and super responsible or this
Beast will will eat someone's face
well then I'm going to say well then no
one should own that animal in a
community because it's just the reality
that most people are not going to be
experts and responsible
all right um K rule C says the trans
dude in the beginning looks a lot like
that Troublesome trans do that gave a
Sonic worker a hard time in that Viral
clip this is a very good catch I didn't
notice this now now so we played
yesterday the uh ABC Houston affiliate
news a report about my speech at the
University of Houston which is coming up
tomorrow and they're planning protests
and antifa is going to show up and they
interviewed some uh people on campus who
are upset about this they also
interviewed a quote unquote trans woman
uh which in other words a male who's
complaining about this and I remember
watching that clip and I'm and I'm
thinking like this person looks familiar
but I don't know from what and this is
it so this is we'll play this clip again
just to remind you this is
from a several months ago
you have this person who goes by Eden
Torres I think now
going to Sonic
and just looking to pick a fight
with the Sonic manager who's just trying
to mind his own business and do his job
let's watch this again
why does it matter oh it doesn't matter
to you I'm sorry I mean but to me
I'm a male
okay okay so what are you so I can call
you a sir or ma'am what are you what
would you assume looking at me what are
you what would you assume looking at me
I assume that you're a man
okay
okay
thank you forever
I love that clip thank you for reminding
me of that
um uh I love that clip because it's just
you know what would you assume based on
looking at me and the guy's like uh
you're a man that's what I was doing you
asked you asked me the question it's a
great this Sonic manager and and this
guy he's like he's he's he doesn't feel
like dealing with this he's not even
trying to stand on some he's not trying
to make some principled stand he's not
interested in doing that he's just
trying to get through the day and uh and
and he deals with enough with enough
a-holes and scumbags like this
so he even says I'll call you whatever
you want me to call you but you got to
tell me what you want me to call you
because I don't know I don't know what
you want
but if you ask me what do you look like
you look and then he flips the camera
around because we're supposed to see
what he looks like and say well how
could you think that that person's a man
and it's like no yeah that looks like a
man with a wig on that's what it looks
like
and you asked don't ask if you don't
want the answer to the question
is one one you know one of the one of
the truths of life one of the rules of
thumb you should always carry with you
and keep in mind is don't ask questions
you don't want an answer to
tried to get the Sonic manager fired
over that and I think unsuccessfully
so that's the happy ending there anyway
that's the person that was uh is going
to be involved in protesting my speech
and I would like to invite Eden Torres
um to the speech you know rather than
standing outside and protesting I want
to invite you to come in sit down watch
the film
you know listen to the speech you can
ask a question in the Q a
back in June of 2020 Candace Owens took
to social media to question the
narrative about George Floyd and took a
barrage of insults as a result
celebrities insulted her GoFundMe de
platformed her as the attacks ramped up
daily wire plus gave her a platform to
speak out without fear being silenced
and supported her investigation into
black lives matter that organization
raised 80 million dollars through
fundraising but no one ever asked where
the money went until now tonight Candace
Owens will reveal the truth in her new
documentary the greatest lie ever sold
exclusively on daily wire plus because
of our members were able to create a
thriving alternative platform and pursue
the truth wherever it leads daily wire
Plus members defeated the vaccine
mandates in the Supreme Court daily wire
Plus members helped us uncover the
Loudoun County sexual assault cover-up
daily wire Plus members empowered
me to expose Vanderbilt's practice of
mutilating children in the name of
gender affirming care and just over the
weekend Delaware Plus members cause
PayPal to backtrack on its orwellian
fines for misinformation so there's a
lot going on we're doing a lot you're
doing a lot together we're doing a lot
remember we are speaking for you and
fighting for your values too free speech
is our greatest weapon and with the
left's iron grip on the culture and the
mainstream media somebody has to step up
and fill the void so if you're not yet a
member go to dailywire.com Walsh to
subscribe and join us today and make
sure you're joined so that tonight you
don't want to miss it 8pm Eastern 7 P.M
Central you're gonna be able to watch
Candace owens's new documentary the
greatest lie ever sold exclusively on
daily wire Plus
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today is the rare but not
unprecedented occasion where a comment
um interest slash maybe annoys me enough
to migrate from the comment section into
the daily cancellation a few days ago
during the segment we discussed the
overall failure of Christian leaders in
this country to make any serious inroads
into the culture and their nearly
perfect record of losing every major
cultural fight for the past many decades
as we discussed some leaders prefer to
stand off at a distance sort of sneering
at those of us in the trenches and
telling us how we might do a better and
Holier job of fighting the battles that
they refuse to fight or have already
surrendered so really the whole
cancellation segment was just my pale
imitation of Teddy Roosevelt's man in
the arena speech I suppose
um you can go and listen to that or read
that and uh because it's much better
much more eloquently put the
the segment generated a lot of feedback
some of it agreeing with my commentary
some of the critical and and that's all
fine this comment however Falls right in
line with the sort of thing we hear from
Christians and Christian leaders
frequently
um it is a sermon about the need to love
our enemies we've talked about this a
little bit on the show kind of
glancingly and I want to get into it in
more detail now
but the sermon is always when we hear
about the way you need to love your
enemies you're not loving enough
it's it's incomplete and lacking the
necessary context
but I'll read the comment because it
kind of sets us up for this conversation
I think in a very nicely so here's the
comment from Casey Stewart it says
Walsh's critique of Cooper and others
like him as well taken at least in large
part but where Cooper goes wrong is in
saying that the problem with Walsh is
that he is political that's not it
problem with Walsh is that he does not
love his enemies he literally admits to
hating them and that taints his entire
project it also makes things more
difficult for those of us who are really
in the trenches I'm an elder in a Bible
Church in the Portland area taking a
solid pastoral stand for Christ on these
and other issues I too appreciate the
work walls of the DW are doing and I am
not calling for them to stop or to try
to add Christian theology to their
public efforts in fact it would be
better if they would talk about God less
then it might be easier for people to
hear me when I say I totally agree with
Walsh about this but from an entirely
different angle that is true of course
but it's hard for people to see because
Walsh's quasi attachment of his religion
to his political work which he does do
implies that he and Jesus are on the
same page on this and they aren't my
message to sexually confused or
gender-confused people is I would die
for you but I cannot lie for you that's
not the message of Matt Walsh or the
daily wire admittedly if it were they
would not have the massive cultural
footprint that they do I get that but
it's not it is not a cowardly shrinking
from the issues to choose to follow
Jesus in the real trenches of pastoral
work rather than to use a media Kingdom
to launch culture War salvos if or when
Walsh Goes to Jail over this it'll be a
media circus when I do probably not if
it won't have any of the flashy Media
stuff about it but God willing will be a
truly it will be truly honoring to my
Lord Jesus
um okay so first of all you're you're
probably correct that if I ever go to
jail it'll be a media circus uh at least
in conservative media
probably the liberal media would ignore
it and I would hope at least on The
Daily wire like I hope it would make it
if me going to federal prison would make
it above the fold them daily wire I
could probably trust that at least
um so you're right about that and and
you could and that does give me a
certain Advantage a certain visibility
that people who are as you say in the
trenches and don't have the platform
don't have and I acknowledge that all
the time you know it's it's it's a lot
harder where you don't I have advantages
with this kind of visibility and uh
leverage and I try to use the leverage
not just for my own benefit but for
um the benefit of of you know these
issues that we're fighting on
uh but it's also true that you know if
anyone ever makes good on their threat
to kill me
um that might be a media circus too but
that's not going to do me a lot of good
because I'm gonna be just as dead
but in any case
you're thrown around words like love and
hate in the way that Christians in our
culture often throw them around
use them without explaining what you
mean by them
and you use them at least at least
you've used them here it seems to me
as a means to elevate yourself above
others so you say you don't love your
enemies like Jesus that I do I would die
for my enemies that's what you declare
is that what loving your enemies means
though that you have to die for them
because if it does nobody walking this
Earth can actually say for sure that
they love their enemies because you
simply cannot know that you would really
die for them unless put in that position
which you almost certainly never will be
and that makes your statement seem like
empty self aggrandizement
as for me I'm happy to admit that in
many conceivable scenarios I would not
die for my enemies I mean I I would not
for example let's just say throw myself
in front of a bullet or a speeding train
to save someone who Advocates or
perpetrates the castration and
mutilation of children that doesn't mean
that I wish death on them I don't and it
doesn't mean that I'd be the one firing
the bullet I of course wouldn't it
simply means that I would not leave my
own kids fatherless in order to Martyr
myself for someone who harms children
indeed I would be sacrificing my life in
order to leave my own children more
vulnerable to the predations of the very
person I have saved
now you might call that brave I would
call it Reckless and irresponsible
it's also not a requirement of loving
our enemies nor does failing to Martyr
yourself for someone mean that you hate
them
there may be some you know there could
be some scenarios where I would put
myself In Harm's Way for those I
consider an enemy I'm not saying it's
that that wouldn't happen ever it's it's
possible you could dream up something
like that all of this is a useless game
of hypothetical however which is what
the love your enemies stuff often turns
into it just turns into hypothetical
doesn't really mean anything no one
explains what they mean by that
what about hatred
well I have never advocated hating your
enemies as a principal I have admitted
that I struggled not to hate those who
inflict unimaginable cruelties on
children
but my struggle in that regard stems
from the love I have for the victims I I
would suggest that if you cannot relate
at all to that difficulty then it's
because you do not love the victims
enough
and yet I'm at fault in this too because
in this confusion I'm also at fault
because when I say struggle not to hate
I don't really mean hate I mean
something more like struggle not to be
totally overcome and blind with rage
that's more what I mean that Temptation
may be a problem in its own right it is
but it's not the same thing as hatred so
here's the part where we should probably
get around to defining our terms
in the immortal words of of whoever
wrote that 90s song What Is Love and
that person argued that love simply
means that baby you don't hurt me yet
that is a negative Vision of Love
Aquinas had a positive issue he said
that love is to will the good of the
other
it means that you want what is best for
someone and you will actively work to
help them accomplish that what is good
what is best for them so what is hatred
then well to hate someone it follows is
to will the bad for them
does that mean that you you hate someone
if you want them to be punished if you
want them to reap the consequences of
their actions if you want them to suffer
for what they've done if you use harsh
language about them if you make them
feel bad no that's not necessarily
hatred at all because suffering and and
Punishment are not bad
when they are deserved they're actually
good in that case they are good for
society and they are good for the person
suffering
a desire for evil to be punished
is born out of an Impulse towards
Justice not hatred
that's the crucial fact that many
Christian churches get wrong or at least
don't spend enough time explaining
there is nothing wrong with wanting
Justice in fact there is something very
wrong with not wanting it enough
and I think that's the real flaw in many
Christians today
an encounter with Injustice should
provoke within you a deep desire for the
Injustice to be righted for it to be
corrected
which means correcting those who
inflicted
I know it sounds scandalous to the
modern Christian ear to hear me say that
we as Christians can even desire
suffering for others but there is no
justice justice without suffering if you
want a killer to go to prison
you want him to suffer because Prison is
suffering that's what it is that's part
of the point of it
of course you want that for his own sake
and for society's sake for justice
I mean even something like putting your
child in time out for hitting his sister
is inflicting suffering it's a very very
very small amount of it for a very very
small infraction but he will suffer in a
very small degree because if he's not
phased At All by the punishment then
there's no point in it
indeed you can actively kill somebody
without hating them
somebody comes into your house in the
middle of the night uh comes into my
house in the Middle Light I'm gonna blow
his brains out of his head and it will
be an act of love love for my family
love for my children as for the dead man
he got was due to him he reaped the
consequences of his actions he got
Justice whether he liked it or not and
we can assume that he did not
so if you can cause someone to suffer if
you can punish them if you can even kill
them in some cases without hating them
then what does hatred mean hatred must
be a desire
for a person's ultimate ill
it is to prefer that they be damned then
redeemed is to wish that they remain
evil so that they could be condemned for
it
it is to want them to remain in sin
I don't know what hatred is if it's not
that
and there's a lot of that kind of hatred
in this culture there's a lot of wanting
people to remain in sin encouraging it
even
now I know this is a word hatred that
gets used by Christians very often to
condemn those who are too harsh too
militant too aggressive
but again they never explain what they
mean
here I am attempting an explanation
and I cannot see that hatred means
anything but
Desiring a person's ultimate final
spiritual destruction
if that's what it means that I could say
for certain that I do not hate anyone
because I want every one of my enemies
to see the error in their ways and
repent I want them all to this very day
I want them this moment to have a change
of heart and abandon their ways I want
every single person who harms children
who abuses and mutilates them to see
themselves for the monsters they become
and turn away from it that's what I want
very much so yes I love my enemies
I don't want them to be my enemies I
want them to stop inflicting evil on the
world and on the innocent but as long as
they're doing such things
I believe we are called as Christians to
oppose them relentlessly aggressively
even angrily at times
we should react to them and their deeds
in a way that is fitting and
proportional we should act with urgency
we should respond to heinous evil and
barbarism in a manner that communicates
just how heinous and barbaric it is
this is where Christians are largely
failing I think
we don't have much of a problem
of Christians hating evil doers too much
or at all
the real problem in our culture and what
has put us in the hole that we're in
is that too many Christians fail to love
virtue and goodness enough and hate evil
enough
um they're not passionate about enough
about protecting the innocent
indifference apathy moral cowardice
these are our most prominent flaws I
would say
these are the poisons in the bloodstream
of the church in the West
that's how I see it
and because I have to cancel something
in order to make this whole rant fit
into the segment that I've chosen it for
uh I suppose they are the things that
I'm canceling today
and that'll do it for this segment of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]